hey youtubers its charlie Merry
Christmas this is gonna be my flash
episode 9 video and yeah I know it's
gonna be off the air for a couple weeks
but don't freak out it is coming back
January 19th the same week as arrow and
legends of tomorrow so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet and there's a new round of the
reverse flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so why
don't we go ahead and make this top 10
just because it's the midseason finale
big freakin episode fattening the flash
up like a goose starting with number 10
Joe and iris talk about what to get
Barry for Christmas my tie gave me this
watch because I could never be on time
gifts that always have secret meanings I
like that idea everything everyone else
is getting for each other is some coded
metaphor for something that's exactly
how fanfiction and fanciers start this
episode in particular did a really good
job of showing the dichotomy between
like the the family stuff that happens
around the holidays and the really WTF
villain flash stuff that's happening but
here the roads revenge you have the zoom
stuff but then you have the family drama
holiday is good for some people really
bad for others on to my number 9 WTF the
actual opening of the episode hands down
my new favorite opening to a holiday
themed episode Merry Christmas
zoom was like I'll totally spare Jesse
quick but you have to help me with
something but even if it wasn't a
flashback he what was happening in real
time it still takes Harrison wells the
entire episode to kind of figure out why
zoom wants Barry so bad he's pushing him
on a hunter so lomon and wally west to
get faster not so that he'll be better
like it was in the comics but so that he
can drink his Speed Force milkshake up
there will be speedster blood on to
number eight though Jay Garrick messing
with Caitlin so very clearly they were
setting them up for a relationship early
in the season so Kailyn is probably just
as awkward as Cisco or Barry you can
argue about which is the most awkward I
think Cisco used to be a little bit more
awkward before Hawkgirl but I just love
some of their dialogue Christmas what's
Christmas and Caitlin just like totally
buying it she's just being super literal
like oh well Christmas is this
celebration she's like seriously no I'm
just I'm just joking we actually have
Christmas on earth too
also turns out that they have the
Godfather on earth - that was another
great line - every earth has the
Godfather there is a lot of relationship
stuff happening on the show right now I
feel like the most enjoyable run right
now at least in this episode was Caitlin
and Jake
because it's the perfect amount of
cheeseball I do love the comedy of Barry
and Patti wearing matching ugly
Christmas sweaters just because it's so
terrible sounding the problem with jokes
like that though is that most people
miss it like most people will watch that
and take it literally like oh that's
stupid they're wearing matching
Christmas sweaters without realizing
that it's supposed to be stupid like
it's being stupid on purpose part of the
fun of some of the humor like the really
awkward you know nerdy geeky humor
between like Caitlin Jay's Cisco Barry
patty is that it's very self-aware like
we're the biggest nerds in the world
let's just have some fun but on my
number seven WTF weather wizard breaks
out Captain cold in the trickster from
prison in the trickster oh man is so
much fun seeing Mark Hamill back this
year even though his role was a little
bit smaller than it was last time
he's just so batshit crazy especially
the broadcast that he does later like
pretty much every time he has a line of
dialogue he has some sort of christmas
pun and I know a lot of people watch
Mark Hamill as the trickster not like oh
he sounds just like the Joker but if you
actually listen really carefully the way
he inflex his voice a little bit
differently he doesn't go quite as high
as the Joker goes the Joker's laugh goes
into like a much higher register either
way I think people are just really
pumped to see him back really the twist
here is where the wizard was just
breaking Captain Cold out because he
owed him one from last year but Captain
Cold is kind of on a hero arc it's more
of antihero I mean he's not a true hero
because he still kind of hates himself
like most villains do like he loathes
himself a little bit but I think he uses
the fact that he owes the flash one for
saving his sister to do something good
without actually having to say that he's
doing something good like he wants to
help Barry a little bit so he's like
okay I'll just I'll use this to clear
the books also a cool thing to note that
a lot of the Rogues know all about Barry
being taken down by zoom earlier but
onto my number six WTF patty learns that
mark Mardon the man who killed her
father is back and goes a little crazy
it's a really intense scene the comedies
kind of tongue-in-cheek cuz Patty's like
I don't have the time to tell you I
can't say it fast enough
Barry's like haha that's that's kind of
ironic but Patty does not know that
Barry knows about Harrison wells of
earth 2 or all the metahumans I know
we're all kind of wondering how Patty's
gonna figure out if she's gonna figure
out herself or Barry's gonna tell her
when I do think it ends up happening I
think it'll be a spectacular explosion
in Barry's face and then the best
possible way
but for most of this episode patty had
her own art to go after Mark Martin that
was her whole thing in this episode she
only crossed paths with the flash
briefly but we do get to find out number
five WTF patty in the flash versus all
the dreidels we do get to find out that
patty has a lot of anger inside of her
over her father dying she blames herself
I was the one that killed him
this was price some of the best
character development that the patty
character has gotten all season I'm
afraid of the guy that I really like
finding out how angry I am she makes it
sound like she's keeping the secret from
Barry that the boy that she really likes
but I don't really consider it a secret
that's on par with like the zoom
Harrison wells secret or Barry keeping
his secret from patty but everybody has
their secrets like Wally West for
instance on a my number five WTF iris
freaks out goes crying to Barry and they
talk to Joe about Wally West boom big
reveal you have a son this is like the
moment where you turn to whoever you're
watching the episode with and yell at
them you know I'm not crying you're the
one that's crying most cry word at the
moment of the episode Wally is short for
Wallace it's what we were gonna name you
if you had been a boy based on their
conversation they make it sound like
Wally doesn't know anything about Joe
doesn't know anything about iris so
Joe's just breaking down throughout the
episode just feeling like he hasn't been
there for his son when he needed them
Barry comforts them and then finally
later in the episode on to my number
four WTF Joe gives Barry the watch I
always meant to give this to my son I
love you here you go it just you know
just another big cry worthy moment of
the episode jesse martin the actor was
just on fire this week he was amazing i
was a little surprised that he gave
Barry the watch though I figured that he
would give it to Wally West but I guess
we're gonna see how that relationships
gonna play out over the back half of the
season but I think him giving the watch
to Barry is just a way for him to show
that you're my son just as much as Wally
is on to my number three WTF team flash
disables all the bombs and Barry stops
Patty from throwing her life away by
killing weather wizard so amazing visual
effects sequence followed by amazing WTF
drama twist ending his life we'll also
in your life all the things that you
love now will be taken away from you who
else thought that Barry was going to rip
his mask off to stop her
just just to like stop her cold in her
tracks so she would pull the trigger
mark Hamill's reaction is just priceless
- he's so bipolar that characters so
bipolar this is so beautiful like he's
full of so much emotion and so much evil
at the same time it's so funny I love
the Christmas fireworks of all the
presents getting sucked up into the
earth - portal - Merry Christmas
fireworks all over the sky and we get a
new lightsaber on the show I see you've
constructed a new lightsaber Barry gets
forced lightning who wore it better Luke
Skywalker taking force lightning or
Barry taking force lightning it would
not be a Mark Hamill episode if there
weren't some Star Wars jokes in there
what a coincidence that this episode
came out the same month that new Star
Wars is coming and also during their
whole fire fire there was like another
Easter Egg for the comic berry running
on the helicopter blades and weather
wizard levitating himself right out of
the comics on a my number two WTF
surprise Christmas guests Wally West
what the hell's gonna happen now so a
Joe being super excited to meet him and
Wally seeming fairly well-adjusted I
guess in the short scene that we've seen
him in it seems like it's gonna be a
fairly positive thing but it's gonna be
a lot of fun seeing all the other
characters to adjust him especially iris
and Joe does anybody else think that Joe
is gonna go into dad overdrive just to
make up for all the years that he and
Wally didn't know each other the
speaking of dads going overboard for
their children on to my number one WTF
Harrison wells agrees to help fatten up
Barry
so that zoom can take his Speed Force a
lot more Speed Force than he normally
would be able to take now the great
appearance by Jesse quick but we finally
learned like what seumas big plan for
Barry is he doesn't want to kill him to
kill him he wants to take his Speed
Force to make himself more powerful now
giving and taking Speed Force is a big
thing in the comics that actually
started around the Wally West era
so right now zoom seems like a cross
between the edward clariss reverse-flash
in hunter zolomon wanting to make the
flash better but also wanting to take
his speed in fact after these scenes i'm
leaning a little bit further away from
Henry Allen being zoom just because if
zoom were Henry Allen then he would know
that Barry is his son of earth 1 and no
matter what the black hole that is his
heart looks like that he would probably
still not want to kill his son no matter
which earth he was from let me know in
the comments what was your favorite
moment from this
episode what do you think about Wally
West and how long do you think it's
going to be before team flash finds out
that Harrison wells is going to
double-cross them do you think that
Harrison wells will come clean to Barry
I mean because Barry essentially came
clean to Harrison wells
without a knowing about it like he was
using Harrison wells to forgive a Oh
Bart Thawne just like Joe letting go of
his hate for his ex-wife you know so
that he could let in the love for Wally
West
so Barry let's go up his hate so he can
let all these good things back into his
life
maybe Harrison wells of Earth too will
do the same thing but in terms of
midseason finales I feel like this is my
new favorite right now well to see if
agents of shield delivers as big of a
WTF supposedly it will so I'm pretty
excited about that what's gonna happen
next is is I actually do have a bunch of
Marvel bonus videos as some Doctor
Strange stuff some Captain America Civil
War I've agents of shield midseason
finale but there's also a trailer for
the rest of the season of the flash so
I'll try to do that sometime this week
too don't forget there's also the arrow
mid-season finale so a couple really
huge things coming in the next day or
two just in case you guys haven't seen
it I did a Supergirl video for the big
you know character reveal I guess I'm
just careful in case you haven't seen it
yet you can click here to learn all
about that all about the character from
the comic books and you can click here
for my Game of Thrones season 6
teaser video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you